when do you think you'll know it's time
to say goodbye to the cameras
dude i didn't think you're gonna ask me
that but
honestly i i want to go ahead and say
goodbye
if i'm being completely honest i'm
watching this season
of mama june road to redemption how do
you feel
about this newest chapter in your life
being all packaged up and being released
out into the world
it's definitely hard because people have
their own opinions you know like people
can be cruel some people can be
nice some people are supportive some
people aren't but
a lot of the times the support and the
love from our fans
honestly is what keeps us going in
production
before we get into this season last
season lots of challenging moments
really tough moments to watch as a
viewer it's your life pumpkin you're
actually
living it so what do you think and how
do you feel when you look back on all
that
it is hard um like even being in
production and stuff going on in our
life
like that was a tough of tough time you
know because
it's like i'm also trying to deal with
it personally and then i'm also having
to film it you know so
i don't want to go back into that mental
place that i was where my mama was and
to
you know her addiction and me having to
step up and do all the things that i was
doing and not really taking care of
myself
because at this point i really do feel
like i have worked hard as a woman like
therapy
and really like working and taking the
time for myself and for my family
i honestly just kind of hate going back
to the past
sometimes i don't think i'm fully
prepared to listen to the
full story just yet only because that is
me trying to protect myself and you
don't want to hear that your mom
spent a million dollars on crack you
know a year you know
that's not something that you really
brag about or can bring up in a
conversation because it's kind of
embarrassing really
i've had um things happen especially
during
um mama's addiction where like i was
trying to apply for jobs and
they wouldn't hire me because they seen
what was going on with her
really yeah one specific job
specifically i was gonna work at an
outlet place
and the lady like that's the first thing
she brought up was like oh your mom is
all in the media and i don't want that
bot to work but it's just like just
because my mom is a certain type of
person doesn't mean that i
am no and pumpkin i am so sorry to hear
that
she's telling everybody that she's sober
but then again i don't believe her
because
you're still with gino so that probably
means still underneath geno's control
and until she gets that out of the way
then she's not really allowed around me
and my family this season on mama june
wrote to redemption
the big theme really seems to be your
and your sister's estrangement
from your mom as she continues to heal
and practice sobriety how is your
relationship with your mom
as it stands today uh as i say this
today like we haven't seen each other in
a year
so that that is very complicated um
going on and on with life and
you know not being able to share those
little moments with my mom i think not
only for me but for alana and even for
ella because
she does love her gigi she does love
being around her
she may be sober but i also don't want
to take any chances because
before when she would say she was sober
she wasn't necessarily sober
so i spoke with your mom about a week
and a half ago as of the 27th of this
month
will be 14 months clean off of cocaine
and been that way no
no relapses do you believe her and and
how do you feel about that
um i definitely do think that this time
is different as far as our sobriety goes
only because
before we were kind of forcing the rehab
on her and this time it was different
she reached out for the help
her and gina both wanted to go to rehab
so it's not necessarily that i'm not
proud of her i just also don't want to
get me or the kids hopes up like i have
several times before so you said you
haven't seen your mom
in a year right okay alana it's been a
little bit longer
so what did i see in the teaser of you
guys having like a sit down
and you'll see that we sit down and meet
after a year and
that's hard for sure like a lot of
emotions there
um it that is definitely going to be a
watch for a lot of people
i feel like me and alana definitely got
things that we needed to get off of our
chest
that she needed to hear in her recovery
process there's a lot of things that i
need to see
i need to see more than 30 days in rehab
i just need
mama to be a different mama i need her
to
not sugarcoat and lie anymore i need an
open line of communication
you know i asked her when i spoke with
her a couple of weeks
ago about you and how you are such a
stellar woman
and um you really deserve a lot of
praise and i command you for all the
great work that you do pumpkin
i want to play you the kind words that
your mom had to say about you
one i mean i'm very proud of her for and
foremost um
you know and our family has always been
close so
does she have to step up no did she
choose to step up
yes am i very grateful for that yes and
i will always be
she's done a damn good job but you know
we've always been so close
that i knew without a shadow of a doubt
when this situation happened
um was it i felt great about it no
sorry hell no i didn't but
you know i knew that
pumpkin wasn't going to allow it to
happen to her yeah
i mean i am very appreciative when mama
is thankful and grateful for the things
that i have done
because i didn't get that in the
beginning and now that she's sober and
in a clear-minded it's great to hear her
say
you know i'm grateful for you and thank
you for taking care of alana because
before like in her addiction she was
like oh i want to choose chooses to live
with you
and it's like no that's that's not the
case
there's a lot of chatter online about
your mom
and the kind of mom that she is i'm
curious if you read any of those things
and how does it make you feel
i don't read any of those things one
thing i will say
is raising being raised by my mother
was completely different than how i'm
raising ella and alana and i want to
continue it to be that way
i don't want to keep things from alana
or ella
i want it to be an open door policies we
didn't have that with my mom growing up
she wasn't the type to say i love you
every time she walked in and out of the
door
she wasn't the type to say i love you
every time you know she hung up on the
phone with us
i want them to live a much healthier
lifestyle and not have so many problems
when they get to my age like mental
health issues and things like
trusting like i have had in the past
you bring up your mental health i just i
want to ask you how are you doing today
oh i'm doing really good like compared
to honestly where i was two years ago
like i've been to therapy um since
september of last year
um and that really helped me you've been
super open and vocal that you're not a
geno fan
we all hated gino because mama picked
him and drugs over us
where does your relationship with gino
stand today um
like you said i don't keep that a secret
like my mama has said several times
there he's not going anywhere and
they're not going to split up in things
so it's like i kind of have to get used
to that i'm also not too concerned
with like fixing things with him from
the past because to me he is a temporary
person my mom has always said like it
would just be
you know her and the girls and it always
has been that way
so ultimately in the end whether it be
five years from now whether it'd be two
months from now and gino and mama split
or something
he's just a temporary person so it's
like why do i want to just waste my time
and fix that the person who was
manipulative and stuff during the
addiction and used your money
and all these things just like you're
just letting them right back in that's
that's a part of the addiction process
she not only had an addiction problem to
drugs she still has a geno addiction
problem
you know i did ask your mom because you
did pumpkin issue an ultimatum
we can't just forgive and forget
overnight you've let a man come between
your kids
she's got to prove to us that she's all
better and i asked her i was like
if it really comes down to it who are
you picking that's a no-brainer
i mean you always pick your kids men
come and go
kids and kids kids in some family always
stay
it's just hard for me because it's a
very argumentative
thing sometimes she'll be like oh no
doubt i'll pick my girls but then
you're still staying in florida with
geno and yes i get it for sobriety but
what happens
after like you could move you know you
know and you're in a better place and
you know you're not going to slip up
and things like that then what happens
are you still going to stay in florida
or are you going to come home
i wouldn't want her to be back to
georgia just so it would be better on
me it'd be better for a lawn it'd be
better for us as a whole family in
general do you think that there's a
world that exists where
you your mom and geno can all peacefully
co-exist
i hope that it doesn't have to come to
that if i'm being honest like i hope
that
he's just not around in like the next
year or the next two years or
however long it takes when was last time
you spoke with him or saw him
um i don't really speak to him like that
look i do want to ask you about social
media because i do see you follow gina
and he follows you
do you guys keep up do you keep up with
each other um no
like i do know during like the mix of
addiction or whatever
um i would just check mama's socials you
know not his
too much because i don't really care
like the stuff that gina poses on his
timeline it's kind of pointless for
me like i feel like i lose brain cells
reading and some of the stuff that he
posted
then why follow him um because i guess
because i followed him from a while back
like before
addiction times and of course you know
your mom and geno
still have their looming court case what
kind of conversations as a family do you
have
to to brace for what may come we talked
about it you know
like if this does happen
we're just gonna have to deal with it i
just kind of learned to let things go i
don't let things stress me out but i
definitely do worry about alana for sure
because
that is her mom like she doesn't want
her mom in jail none of us want mama in
jail
but you know we also know that there was
consequences behind her recovery
you know i love being a mom what with
these like terrible twos about to be
three
i'm about to pull my hair out i need a
break i want you to take a second and
and kind of reflect on the maturity
you're a wife you're a mom
you're a guardian and you're you're only
21. yes you're a woman but you're still
young
right how does all of that feel how does
that weigh on your shoulder
before like i couldn't handle it it was
just too much
like it's just completely different
raising a three-year-old and a 15 year
old like
at all you know like one you just kind
of like oh yeah get a toy and you go
about your day
but alana needs a 200 pair of shoes or
something and it's like that's hard for
me sometimes because
you know we work normal jobs too we do
this filming thing but
we're not millionaires we're not kim
kardashian you know we don't make that
type of money
and it is stressful when like some
months we had to let bills pass because
alana needed a new pair of shoes or
someone she had to let a bill pass
because
evelyn needed new clothes we always make
sure that the kids have more
than we had at their age and is alana
still currently living with you
yes she is this is actually her bedroom
oh
you're in alana's bedroom yeah yeah i
know because this thank you is popping
up
how is she doing today she's doing a lot
better honestly like ever since she come
back to school
she's got like a 93 in the class and
it's really been catching up on our
assignments
so i mean i'm very impressed with elana
like considering where she was two years
ago both of us like in the state of mind
that we were in the situations that we
were going through
we really have overcome that i've lost
40 pounds and i really am trying to do
better
you know you don't have to brag about
your whole 40-pound weight loss
you know it wouldn't hurt you to eat a
few vegetables like i do we also see a
little bit on the show
you talking about your health and your
health journey so i'm curious how are
things going where are you at with all
of that
um things have been going great two
years ago like in the midst of mama's
addiction before
she went to rehab and stuff i just kind
of found myself like laying around the
house
eating all the time just like drinking
sodas whenever i wanted to
and i just noticed like i started
getting bigger i was like 280 and now
i'm like
220. eventually i do want to
just only get a tummy tuck because i am
just very
insecure about my stomach well i think
and i support you doing whatever you
need to do to
feel your best
oh i feel dizzy we've watched you grow
up on television over the last
decade when do you think you'll know
it's time to say goodbye to the cameras
dude i didn't think you're gonna ask me
that but
honestly i i want to go ahead and say
goodbye
if i'm being completely honest only
because
alana grew up doing this um and you
don't really have
a normal life during production you
don't we have two days off a week and i
can't get my life together in two days
i enjoy doing the show i enjoy the
income that it brings i enjoy the lives
that we
impact but it's just like ultimately i
want to go and be a nurse at a hospital
i want to go and make an impact in a
hospital somewhere
tv is not something that i think any of
us
really want to do anymore but we kind of
just keep pushing ourselves
yeah i mean i are are you still in it
like for the next couple years or do you
think this this
decision to go to nursing school could
that happen pretty soon
i mean i think i could make the decision
whenever i wanted to quite
frankly but you know with contracts and
everything there's
more much more complicated than it
really is alana as well wants to be able
to
be a teenager and not have to worry
about like okay i have to go film today
at two o'clock
instead of like okay i can't hang out i
want to go hang out with my
friends it is very complicated because
we miss out on very important things and
a lot of people don't realize that
they're like oh well
you know the money's nice you won't make
that anywhere else and it's like that
may be true
but i also can't get back all the
birthdays i've missed from josh's family
i also can't get back the family
reunions
you know birthday parties um
christmases and things like that that i
have missed yeah it's definitely a
trade-off
do you ever wish that reality tv had
never
entered your life do you feel like it
you know took away from your childhood
i say yes because i feel like i took
away from our childhood
you know and i do feel like you know it
was so quick
you know everything like i was 11 alana
was six and we've been doing it
ever since then you know and it's
frustrating like i said you can't go and
do things but then i also
say no because that it didn't ruin our
childhood because we were able to do a
lot more things
than the average people that were our
age i'm very grateful for
the things that tv land has kind of
brought to us and
been able to allow us to do but
it definitely is getting to the point
where it's kind of like i think it's
time for us to say goodbye
i mean do you have a timeline on that i
don't have a timeline
okay you're just starting to feel the
itch and you might be ready
i mean all of us have been kind of
feeling the itch for a long time now but
then it's like oh you get your contract
and you know it's like well we really
need the money
well would you consider doing a spin-off
series i'd honestly probably just
convert to youtube or tick tock because
like people are making money on there
you know
and ultimately i do want to do youtube
like just with um just with the little
family that we have here in our house
like me
josh jessica and alana and ella i think
that we could be funny i think that we
could
make that you know kind of like a source
of income as well and also just for fans
to kind of
keep up